how come you don't laugh
n ain't you got something to make you
just
[Music]
smile my sister and I ain't seen her in
years you know if you ain't going to
laugh you need to sell your footy
[Music]
bone I was married to a man I didn't
love whatever I say
[Music]
go and he took my sister away from me
even if we have to part you and me let's
have one
heart how come you so nice don't know
maybe you too
nice you seem like trouble I come here
out of
respect but if then there ain't nothing
to get that show ain't nothing to
[Music]
get now I got your
attention here's what you man need to
hear drinks on the house P the button
there going to be some changes
made you got to stand up
I know my sister somewhere in the
world someday we're going to meet
again keep your head held high just like
mom taught us it's time i' be free from
you and then took into creation I died
before I let that happen good that's
just a going away present I've been
needing bab baby
[Music]
baby what are you got to do time for you
see the world push the
button sweet and loving God POS your
word
com